et indiqué que le préfet après
concertation avec la mer va étendre le
port du masque dans l'ensemble de la
capitale et la question évidemment se
pose pour la petite couronne compte tenu
des circulations entre ces territoires
et à marseille des dispositions
complémentaires ont été prises c'est ce
à quoi vous faites allusion madame
notamment sur la fermeture anticipée de
certains établissements en fait d'après
les données dont nous disposons
les deux zones effectivement dépasse les
50% milles qui les classe dans la même
zone mais à ce jour
jusqu'à ce jour il y a des indicateurs
encore plus dégradée dans le sud
notamment
notamment concernant les personnes âgées
qui comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
sont des personnes plus vulnérables
notamment sur le taux de positivité des
tests et qui a pu conduire qui a conduit
effectivement envisager des mesures je
parlais tout à l'heure de gradation un
peu plus importante un peu plus sévères
à marseille mais mais soyons clairs nous
sommes vigilants sur l'évolution de la
situation et les mesures qui doivent
être prises le seront en fonction des
circonstances